das kind zu und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge das game das
neuerdings neu ist ak jump league und
wir haben die erste neuerung kommt man
hier
es gibt jetzt von anfang an hier sowohl
ein holzschwert als auch diese lieder
rüstung ja das ist aber nicht das was
ich euch heute hauptsächlich erzählen
will sollen dann ich möchte euch gerne
mal so ein bisschen berichten was gerade
bei mir in meinem leben passiert damit
dir vielleicht auch verstehen können
warum gewisse sachen passieren und
brauchen gewisse sachen auf die tube
unterbleiben und ich passieren können
und zwar ich stelle euch einfach mal
exemplarisch heute meinen tag vor als
ich war gestern abend noch ein bisschen
enger was okay so bis zum 23 und da bin
ich heute morgen entsprechend um 8 auf
höhere macht komme ich dann den halo den
block da komm ich am morgen & morgen um
halb elf morgens aufgestanden dieser
zeit um 1000 mal angesetzt g.co sagt
richtig ist denn los mit der er fast
letzte
ok ach leute irgendwie kann ich gerade
nicht in dieser aufnahme kann ich keinen
job im spiel vorkommt ja danke okay so
bin ich aufgestanden und dann bisschen
rum getrödelt ich musste noch ein paar
sachen erledigen und dann weißt du drei
an der uni ja und dann war ich jetzt bis
gerade eben und wir haben jetzt elf jump
es kein vorbild schreibt einer handel
dann kriege ich den anbieter
nein mostra machen können das mit
abstand das schwierigste in diesem leben
wohl jetzt muss ich so schaffen
ja und ich habe einfach über moment
überhaupt keine zeit für so was also ich
weiß nicht mit müsst ihr mal andere
leute anschauen die machen
wahrscheinlich deutlich weniger und
kommen auch nicht hinterher mit denen
mit youtube so und ja keine ahnung also
zeit schon gerade mega stress ich will
nicht dass hier denkt dass ich euch
irgendwie nicht mehr schätzen würde pro
jahr
im gegenteil sehr gut niemand kennt
youtube auf diesen server aus gummi
niemand kennt youtube auf diesen server
aus dem ok angst
dann ist alles klar gut dann nehme ich
halt zurück
ja sehr schön fürs trägerschaft ja und
momentan ist mein leben hat richtig
richtig stressig ich bin dann in der
vorbereitung auf die wahrscheinlich
heftigste person phase meines lebens ich
schreibe vier klausuren jetzt an vier
tagen nächste woche ich habe erst
freitag eine und am montag dienstag
mittwoch donnerstag und montag dienstag
mittwoch so richtige mörder dinge also
die absoluten angstgegner keine ahnung
erhalt statistik und mathe und also ich
mag meinte weiss gott aber dass ein
richtig richtig schwierige fächer weil
die profs auch teilweise richtige
arschlöcher sind ein team
die klausur bewusst zu stellen das
irgendwie nur klagen dass irgend ein
riesiger teil durch fällt so und das hat
schwierige sache deswegen muss ich mich
momentan ein bisschen neu fokussieren
und gucken was ist aktuell wichtiger und
ich denke versteht auch wenn ich jetzt
sage momentan ist einfach das studium
wichtiger weil es sozusagen einmalig und
ich muss jetzt meine klausurphase mal
ran kürzen ich mache sonst weiß gott
schon nicht so viel wegen youtube weil
dieser zeit verbraucht was sonst auch
schon eher weniger als die anderen und
mutter dann komme ich trotzdem ganz gut
klar
aber jetzt muss ich halt wirklich mal
sagen okay eins von beidem
und dann mag ich war eine sache richtig
als beide so halten und die eine sache
ist jetzt für mich halt das studio ja
aber es gibt ich habe heute schon auf
twitter verkündet es gibt sehr sehr
rosige aussichten für
mich und für euch und zwar ist es der
januar denn januar im januar locker
nehmen januar habe ich komplett frei den
ganzen monat und kann dann sehr schön
den ganzen tag videos machen und
streamen vorliegende stream will ich
wieder hinein steht jetzt bin ich wieder
ganz unten alten abschlüssen bin okay
aber der erste nicht zu viel abstand ist
einfach nur raten sehr das feld ist sehr
dicht beieinander
ok gas geben jetzt müssen vielleicht
aufholen bisschen ja dann kann ich
wieder live streams mache ich bin doch
gerade im gespräch mit meinem netzwerk
die wahlbriefe jetzt die situation ist
wegen mit wunschpartner
ich hoffe die haben da schon ein kleines
nikolaus geschenk für mich oder so ein
verspätetes ein verfrühtes
weihnachtsgeschenk glaube ich dass ich
fit partner werde das wär super dann und
auch wenn ich kein trainer bin wird es
im januar richtig für das rematch geben
auf jeden fall vor allen dingen war ich
dann ja wieder zu hause bin
weil max und dann habe ich dann wieder
die geile leitung alter das wird so geil
videos hochladen in einer minute streams
in 8000 wechsel whatever
das wird richtig geil leute ich freue
mich drauf und ich finde es schön mit
shampoos meinen live your life changing
superhero benoten
jetzt haben uns ein bisschen gefangen
oder nee aber es gibt immer noch viele
müssen uns jetzt hat auch folgen darauf
fokussieren also ich gehe jetzt wieder
bis hin zum gameplay über merkt ihr
bisschen weg vom vom von der story dlc
etappe über mein leben
ja okay wir sind platz eins
sehr schön gedreht die ganze sache sehr
gut kommen hier ja jetzt ist jeder mal
ein kleiner kritische sprung gemeistert
nice nice nice
nehme ich mit in stein schwertes sehr
gut wo wir noch zwei eisen jetzt günstig
und crafting dann könnten wir doch sehr
gut gas geben der match bis dato sieht
das alles sehr gut aus
ich werde vielleicht so einfach kann
vielleicht hatte ich das hier ein
bisschen zusammen diese drangphase
vielleicht auch er nicht muss ich mal
schauen
also ich hoffe wie gesagt leute noch mal
will es noch mal sagen also ich will
nicht dass jetzt irgendwie also ich will
jetzt weiß gott nicht mit dankbarkeit
irgendwie erhaschen oder so aber ist
halt schon so dass ich relativ viel
investiere jetzt gerade an zeit also
abbaut
sagen wir mal relativ gesehen weil ich
als extrem wenig zeit habt und dann
trotzdem hat noch hier mich abends hin
setzte also ich denke mal stimmen vor
was ist mir vorstelle gar nichts vor ich
denke mal jeder andere mensch will
irgendwie abends nach hause kommen und
würde pieps sagen oder quax sagen wie
man so sagt man sparen
hanappi und würde einfach nichts machen
aber ich setze mich halt abends noch mal
hin
nachdem ich jetzt schon acht oder zehn
stunden gelernt habe und machen ein
video für euch und weil ich das einzige
was ich mir irgendwie er hoffe ist halt
dass ihr das zu schätzen bist und ich
will jetzt auch gar nicht irgend jetzt
sogar irgendwie sagen gebt mir 3000
läufst sonst schätzt er es nicht will
ich nicht
deswegen kommt auch kein aber nach
diesem satz bleibt einfach so im raum
stehen
jetzt trifft die pille ist vielleicht
dass jetzt auch wieder bisschen tricky
momentan läuft aber ganz gut weil der
hintergrund im gebiss sind normalerweise
sollte der hintergrund also das was ich
unter den wolken sehen dass ihr schwarz
sein dann kann man nämlich die schwarzen
wolken kaum vom hintergrund trennen so
visuell
dementsprechend ist es dann sehr
schwierig zu treffen und wo leute ich
will einfach gerade fast noch ab wir
müssen gas geben aber da noch nicht mehr
ziel kommt gg alles klar ich hoffe ich
hoffe der handelsstopp herzlich
geschafft hier haben wir unseren kompost
und jetzt könne ein bisschen gas geben
im deathmatch
ich habe übrigens was ich habe übrigens
pro ja okay danke danke danke danke dass
wir nicht die bibel zum mörder combo
gibst okay also schlechtigkeit spiel
also ich meine pfeile auf vom für den 8
der wischt ein auch ich habe auf dem
server so eine schlechte ranger ich
gesagt kann ich nicht verstehen wieso
andere leute mich an unseren trotz zu
erwischen
ja um die ecke gibt auch noch um die
ecke ist alter was ist los mit dir vor
der frist hat auch so viel ja ok oh gott
oh gott oh gott oh gott oh gott ich mich
echt ein bisschen geld klarkommen
die jazzwelt ist hat immer krasser immer
echt viel eingesteckt ich muss einfach
ein bisschen regenerieren
okay wer das gedacht fanboy gaylord
alles klar
ok warum verweigert weil erzigkeit
petterweils nachdem wir gekämpft
okay das wochen sehr sehr hass
getriebener menschen kann ich jetzt so
im raum helfen ist als das wird auch in
jeder anderen konstellation passieren
wäre ich jetzt kein youtuber und er ich
weiß gar nicht wat meine videos keine
ahnung macht er wahrscheinlich sowieso
nicht weiß was das wieder für eine
aussage also nein keine ahnung ich weiß
es natürlich nicht wir müssen fällt er
davon ausgehe dass das nicht macht weil
die quantität der aller derer die meinen
videos schauen
länger ist als die lehrer die meine
videos nicht schauen deswegen schaut mir
vielleicht eher davon ausgehen können wo
ich habe den key bekommen jetzt kann ich
die regeneration drin genau die wollte
ich nämlich und jetzt muss ein bisschen
laufen alter und er wäre bisschen stress
sagt x factor läuft eigentlich er hat
eine deutlich schlechtere rüstung also
wir jetzt in sauberen trennung noch
machen komme ich gehe um die ecke und
dann ab jetzt klingelt an der tür und da
vorne sind heute okay er hat mich
erwischt
alles klar wie ging das ich will jetzt
gar nicht so war muss ich sagen nicht so
warm farbigkeit aufgaben die tür gehen
23 uhr und die sache ist hätte ich mach
jetzt das video für euch nehmen dass ihr
auf und danach geht es direkt weiter
dann noch eine stunde lernen also ich
bin extra früh aus der uni gegangen
damit es ein video machen kann weil ich
hab irgendwie schlechtes gefühl wenn ich
jetzt wenn du so lange kein video kommt
ja jetzt jetzt aber erst einmal geht
gibt's ja nicht jetzt aber normalerweise
sind die death matches hier bei jump
blick einfacher als das heutige das
heute ist echt bisschen schwierig aber
wir haben noch gute chancen ok einzigen
einsetzt und wir haben vom feiern zu
können ist dass der mit der die ages
plate falls ja problem falls nicht nicht
so großes problem
wo ist so jetzt kommt bei mir hey du du
mit dj s der mit der lehrerschaft alles
klar
okay das ist schon ein gutes zeichen für
uns so kommt jetzt hier eine in die
fresse hast du aus dem fahrzeug etwas
mit dem land
gerade nicht getroffen habe das gesehen
ich habe ihn gerettet so aber irgendwie
ziemlich getroffen trotzdem gebäuden
leute sehr gut
ja ihr könnt gerne mal eure meinung dazu
sagen so zu diesem thema uni stress mit
youtube vereinen und irgendwie die
hobbys so gegeneinander abzuwiegen und
auch dieses gefühl als youtuber dass man
irgendwie das also ganz persönlich für
mich halt nicht so gut wenn ich keine
videos mache für euch irgendwie kann ich
finde es halt irgendwie ich weiß nicht
was gut oder schlecht ist aber wenn ich
das wenn das so schleift und kann videos
kommen da finde ich das irgendwie
schlecht
ich hab mir die kommentare was ihr davon
haltet wir sehen uns beim nächsten video
wieder das gerne daumen nach oben an
sich gefallen hat haut rein macht's gut
und scharf